people who buy things are suckers look
around me it's amazing several months
ago I was on a walk and found my crib
tree I approached the tree murdered it
left it to cure in my wood shop and have
begun working it into a crib for my
upcoming child Ron Swanson you cannot
use this crib you're ignoring every
known crib safety standard it's all
covered in the parenting book I'm
reading are you going to crawl my way by
Lenny Kravitz my crib will be safe
because I'm building it with my own two
hands I bought my crib in Bloomington
and I am confident that it is literally
the safest Crib in the explored universe
let me take you there and you can talk
to the salesperson counter offer you
take me nowhere and I talk to no one
counter-counter offer you come with me
or I make you attend a four hour fax
cover sheet protocol meeting either way
it's a win for me
Ron what's this the crib I built
I'm giving it to you and Anne it's
perfectly safe I tested it by hitting it
with my truck Well Ron I can't accept
this is for your baby there's more than
one crib Tree in a forest that's not a
lesson by the way just a comment on
Lumber availability
it's beautiful thank you nobody has all
the right answers in parenting including
me and that toxic crib you bought won't
be the last mistake you make but a man
who is this worried about making all the
right choices cares very much that's all
that matters you'll be a great father
thank you Ron for the crib and the
advice it's much better than any
metaphor
does the white whale actually symbolize
the unknowability and meaninglessness of
human existence
no it's just a fish
morning Leslie
did you have a good night
good document what is that this is what
I did last night after I got home I
drank six more glasses of whiskey and
then I finished crafting this small harp
using a bandsaw a Spoke shave and an
oscillating spindle sander
oh
beautiful but wait there's more here are
some photographs of me drinking the
whiskey you'll notice I'm holding up
yesterday's newspaper so you can tell
that I'm not lying
I feel like I'm in a spa
[Music]
I haven't even started yet I know
I thought you could use some help what
city Planet guys can be real pains in
the ass you know
okay I just want you to know that I
still don't think city codes Ron shut up
would you please
I'm taking a half day off to come and
help you out because you're my friend so
just
shut up
no I'm bringing my workshop up to the
Swanson code and if the Swanson code
happens to overlap with the city
government code shut up
merry congrats to Christmas what half
Merry Christmas have congratulations
because I just received some news you
Ron Swanson have been nominated for an
award from the Indiana fine woodworking
Association how did you hear about that
I've had a Ron Swanson Google alert for
seven years and it finally paid off
recently I made a chair
when I was finished I thought it was a
good chair
I submitted it to the Indiana fine
woodworking Association who felt it
merited consideration for an award
it's been a real Whirlwind I know you
didn't but if you had gone to Hogwarts
Academy which house do you think you
would have been in well obviously I want
to say Gryffindor but I've got to go
with Hufflepuff I respect your honesty
Gryffindor
Seeker on the Quidditch team Diane
that's mature right there it's beautiful
Ron yours is the winner I'm not sure I
stand a chance hey you most certainly do
crazy not to vote for you which one is
Rose
how much do you think Ann would miss
this sconce I don't know it's part of
her house
well okay it's not rocket science
I removed the sconce fired up my
grandfather's torch heated up the pieces
in a cast iron bucket liquefied the
metal pour it into a mold obviously keep
it over a little flame to achieve a nice
temper cool The Nanny freeze and just
forged and shaped the Rings
any with a crucible and a settling
torch and a cast iron waffle maker could
have done the same whole thing only took
me about 20 minutes
people who buy things are suckers
evening gentlemen oh hey hail zorp it is
a beautiful night for the end of the
world congratulations to all of you for
reaching the Finish Line the zorpees are
ridiculous but like the founding fathers
I believe in absolute freedom of
religion also their ceremonies require
the playing of flutes
I happen to make flutes in my wood shop
flutes are eighty dollars a piece and
Recorders are 150. hey they're beautiful
would you take a check you can cash it
to tomorrow sure
guys what are you doing here come in
you caught me before my first run of the
day I call it my beat the sun run it's a
race between me and the sun well we got
one more gift for you it's quarterstone
zebra wood joined by floating tenons to
the black walnut Corner posts finished
with a wiping varnish that's a secret
Swanson Family Recipe handmade at my
wood shop and you are correct it is
gorgeous
starting a new life with your new family
so it's an empty buddy box to fill with
memories for your little buddy or
Twizzlers that's the beautiful thing
about a box we all burned our initials
in see
wait a minute who's
g-j-l-g-gg that's Gary Jerry Larry
gergichenger I burned in all my names I
really I didn't know what to do
well um
thank you
um this tear
um caused by the overwhelming
thoughtfulness of my friends
will be my baby's first memory
salt water will warp the wood so keep
your tears in your eyes where they
belong
will do Ross Watson hey I moved our
meetings to tomorrow because you are
drunk and hungover simultaneously at two
in the afternoon yeah a good call also
you have a visitor no whoever it is I
have zero interesting hello
we just spent 12 hours together woman I
don't care I have three years worth of
hugs to force upon you against your will
I have a small object for you call it an
official peace offering I suppose wow
this is very sweet but
six hours ago the frame is the gift when
my company took on the Morning Star
Development and I realized it meant
bulldozing Anne's old house I salvaged
her front door then I stripped off all
the terrible paint and lacquer people
really don't know how to finish wood
properly and I made it into this frame
for you in the event
that you and I ever
run you big fat giant sap that seems
unnecessary
okay